uh it's uh the [ __ ] he makes is so
you know how like people make stuff and
it's like you can you i love this the jr
heart tattoo yes
but like people will make things and you
go okay you know they they do it where
it's good enough and you go i see what
you did there very funny but then
there's people like ballysong who can't
just kind of make a meme
he has to make this look like it would
go on a box for a nintendo game like he
can you know he's such an obsessive dude
like no it has to be perfect and at the
end and at the bottom here it says
nincompoops instead of nintendo but you
know the other fun the other thing is
bali song is so good that he sent me a
message he goes i don't know i think
people are going to think i'm being nice
to them
because you know it is a good picture it
is but it's not a nice no it's not nice
it's not nice um
yeah one of those guys is a 52 year old
father so there's no way to make that
and go you're cool bro
this this is really really really good
uh he's on twitter if you want the
picture then get him some [ __ ]
some followers all right um
so
and by the way
shout out to let me give the the correct
posted by
not a reddit taka
not a reddit taco posted this on the uh
fighter and the kid
subreddit am i correct yeah and
what's funny is right this was four days
ago yeah how long ago was it when when i
honed in on him like oh he's had it with
you yeah they've posted that clip of us
talking about it on the fighter and they
picked up on it and now they're they're
kicking it up a notch these guys are
going way deep with this so that now
we're i think we're establishing that
these two all right so let's let's let's
check this out
the first half we've seen but we'll play
it again for a little
reminder yeah
for a if if it [ __ ] plays the thing
is this is just a reddit video i might
have to
i might have to refresh give me a second
because they just uploaded it to reddit
all right here we go just keep doing it
dude
how do you know
uh
just around is he is he hanging i've
never seen him once
he goes there sparingly huh
i don't know
he he
there's a lying tone in his voice yeah
yeah
yeah he comes around because he counts
like i've never seen him at the company
he's from cal is always the comedy store
so he would know right
uh no well new york he's on saturday
night live but he comes out here too is
he still on us now oh yeah
he's great man
just one more question that's like uh
just one more question you know what it
is though that would be like if roy said
like some female friend right and i
claimed to have [ __ ] her right and now
you know royce is like oh so-and-so is
going to come hang out and i'd be like
yeah and you'd be like you said you
[ __ ] her right like yeah dude
look where did i look where were you
saying oh you know around like just
hanging out whatever like that's the i'm
oh no is this person really coming here
and i'm going to have to face this like
that's that's the oh no i'm going to get
him
that's like not only that but he's
acting like if the girl told me i didn't
[ __ ] him what are you talking about i
already knew the information but i
wasn't telling you yeah but just yeah
like it's you know around town at the
you know the
the bar the one with the
you know the tvs so there's this one but
there's there's there's i've always been
a fan of there's
been nice to me it was great to me
what else you got so he's trying to move
on love his baseball he started the big
dick energy ariana grande started with
him
he just does look like he might have a
big dick i don't know he just does
like lanky you know lanky yeah that's
how it goes i like the loose big dick
energy council this is lanky [ __ ] boy
falls in though dude but i don't know
what else to do man so this is him this
is on the bonfire okay it's not that i'm
violent or i like beating people up i
just had no other option well from
speaking to you you said kind of quite
the contrary that you were not violent
and then the fighting very much were you
in a lot of street fights in your life
no no no no zero zero
one ever in college and then that's
about it my brother was zero but one so
he's the one getting fights and beating
me up but
my parents thought he would be the cage
fighter and i'd be freaking on saturday
night so that first mma she went listen
i just got done [ __ ] seven dudes
there's nothing in my body that would go
through my mind to kill her that does
not exist in me
any fight i've ever been i've been in
way more fights than you never once you
haven't you've been out you've been
you've also been in um what i'm saying
is you've also been talking about street
fights right i'm talking about i've been
street fighter i've been more street
wait a second
wait a minute wait a tick
wait a tick
what was that brendan is this because
we're jealous and don't play sports that
that makes you a [ __ ] liar
so on
so on the bonfire
he's telling uh big j okerson
and dan soder he's telling him i don't
get industrial one street fight one now
he's telling brian gallon that he's in
every street all the streets every
street fight that's ever happened i was
love me
please love me please just accept me at
this point i'll take that i'll take
acceptance and when you buy your pants
you know you're allowed to buy pants to
go down to your ankles right like you
don't have to wear the [ __ ] milhouse
pants you've been more than i've been i
don't i've been i've been growing up
rich
hold on hold on don't well he he did
grow up rich to be fair let's give bren
let's give brendan a uh one point if
we're adding points
point to fighter one fight point to the
kid
he's the kid with the 52 year old's the
kid right the 52 year old kid and then
the one who lost his
biggest fight ever is the fighter the
one who looks like the kid of a single
mom who dresses like the dad ain't [ __ ]
hold on hold on don't tell me that cuz
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you've been more fights
than me i've been as many fights as
you've been in oh my god
well okay again to let to be fair to
call in here though just because you've
grown up rich doesn't mean you're you
don't get into fights right like i went
to private school out of my life private
christian school and there were a lot of
kids that grew up rich that were still
[ __ ] problems that would still get
into fights every day so
in the street i know you dude you don't
fight i know you don't tell me that oh
my god wait wait wait why you don't know
me you don't know how i grew up as in as
in getting in fights in a bar you all
you almost saw me get in two fights
since you've known me what are you
talking about
uh and i am in the highway says kellen
is known for getting in fights uh the
singer from cro-mags knew him in the
punk days and surprised always fighting
in the clubs that's okay fine i'm not
saying he's not here's my problem right
you're 52 year old father
why are you digging in over this divorce
father no yeah but recently divorced 52
year old divorced father and going no
[ __ ] bro i've been way more [ __ ]
bar in street fights than you dude
what is like what is wrong with the
person that thinks that's cool who
watches this and likes it dude [ __ ]
i punched way more i have a way worse
temper and a way worse developed
personality than you bro fix your
glasses because you look like you look
insane sorry you're good i'm just
helping you [ __ ] headphones they like
clamp down on the [ __ ] headphones
no these are like [ __ ] vice versa
i've been in more street fights than you
headphones are not supposed to be like
vice grips i've worn more headphones
than you okay i'll have you but
seriously a 50-something year old man
who's a father who doesn't see his kids
he's too busy at the comedy store
and he's like no no i have way more
anger issues than you bro i have way
more personality and character flaws
dude
i fight way more in bars dude
okay i guess who would want to win that
argument i would go
okay
all right man you fight more you sound
like a fun guy to go out with you know
what's really fun when you're in your
50s right and you want to go out with
your buddy but your buddy
is still so unreasonable and so
unpredictable that it's not worth going
out with him you know i mean like like
like would we even gone to miami this
weekend if i was just always getting us
into fist fights you go
i don't want to go man because you're
gonna as soon as we get down we're gonna
take two bites of mistake and be like
the [ __ ] you looking at dude that's like
but it's the waiter he just wanted to
know if you wanted more water this goes
along with the whole persona right
because the whole
every dude you knew in high school the
ones that would talk about sports and cr
and crushing puss were also the ones
that would say oh [ __ ] you up i got into
a fight with this dude last night it's
this jock mentality that they have it's
really weird like that's what matters
what matters to them is how many people
they beat up in bars and
and and how cool they are and how many
sports they played and it's like you
said you're in your 50s nobody nobody
cares about that anymore if you're in
your early 20s
this kind of conversation this kind of
[ __ ] makes perfect sense right i mean
especially like if you're 20 in your
early 20s if you're one of those like uh
jockey types anyway if you're in
football or you know what i mean maybe
you got a football scholarship i'm not
talking like division one but any kind
of college football program you're
probably gonna crush some beers maybe a
little bit of roids and maybe on the
weekends you are gonna be like [ __ ]
dude i punch way more people in the face
than you that you know when you're in
your 20 52 year old father
who's divorced and again
probably spends a lot more time at the
comedy store than helping his kids with
their homework just saying
i know you dude you don't fight i know
you don't tell me that oh my god wait
wait wait why you don't know me you
don't know how i grew up as in as you
don't know me 52 year old man again
saying you don't know
he's speaking like a pregnant 13 year
old on maury poverty when cartman
remember when cartman played you know
i i kill people and i rape people you
don't know me exactly he's about to say
catch me outside he really is [ __ ]
cartman's character yeah that's what he
is
you don't know i do what i want i do
what i want you don't know how i grew up
as in as in getting in fights in a bar
you almost saw me get in two fights
since you've known me that's reasonable
behavior in your and you've not in
you're in his 50s though you've almost
seen him get into two fights why
imagine being no because i'm trying to
think about this like you so let's say
we didn't we didn't go to a show in
tampa because we went to south florida
let's say we would have gone let's say
we would have done something and what do
you think he would have tried to fight
us
i'm being serious like if he's that
hot-headed probably i would a lot of
it would have been hilarious
i'm not above that [ __ ] i'm really not
i'm sorry i used to be when i was
younger yeah i'll do this myself now i'm
in my 30s i'm like i will three on one
you know
what do you want from me i don't care
[ __ ] tupac did it he was cool
hey you know what that that's a t-shirt
idea tupac stopped the [ __ ] out of
somebody with like eight other dudes at
the mgm grand nobody the next day went
you know tupac it's pretty lame well to
be fair he got shot and murdered
immediately after but whoa wait what had
he been alive he died yeah
yes that's tragic who's the guy who's
the guy hosting family feud
that's steve harvey i just thought two
puck real mustache
that's a thicker mustache i can't tell
if you're really really stupid they wore
the same suits i can't tell if you're
really really racist or just really
stupid but it's not too bad a little bit
of column a little bit of column b
you pick i don't care
you pick out the ratio i don't know
what are you talking about don't say
that you don't have the kind of temper i
do don't don't act like you've been in
more fights you're acting like all i
grew up rich first of all
can you imagine a guy with that temper
how great he must have been to be around
with his wife and his kids like because
if he because when you have a temper
like that there's not people that have
street fighting tempers and that are
very also nice to their family like that
carry that [ __ ] carries over like all
the dudes that i've known that have
tempers like this punch holes in drywall
you know what i mean like all the dupe
it you don't you don't shut it off right
like there's ufc guys well like there's
ufc guys that actually don't get in the
street fights that are perfectly cut
because they're like okay i'm in the
octagon this is my job this is what i'm
doing yeah they're not getting into bar
or home no they're very chill dudes that
only once every six months are like i'm
gonna murder this dude right right right
back to my regular life but
i can't imagine you were lovely to be
around no he it definitely there's a
sort of like a cancerous anger there
yeah it's
more fights with than you brian what how
many fights you've been in oh by the way
all because i'm going to clip this and
then the the the sycophants that follow
them are going to go you guys are okay
fine looking
fat
virgin stupid whatever i don't care uh
we don't crush puss we don't play sports
right we don't play sports explain to me
that's fine just answer me this question
explain to me
how we didn't just catch brendan schaub
in a lie he was just caught in because
right we're making fun of callum for his
attitude and that's fine but remember
this shabba is saying he's been in more
street fights than brendan
after he said i didn't get in the street
fights my brothers did
or my brother did yeah
i couldn't even count
you i i know you i know a lot of people
you grew up and you
those neighborhoods where you hear kids
playing all the time after school lets
out of course it's just one of those
where you see little little
little squeals of joy and ice cream
trucks riding past it it's ridiculous
when you go to bed and if you get forget
to lock your cart or you're like it'll
be fine i'm not getting up i'm not
getting up for this
it's the way we grew up b
yeah i i fought plenty in high school
and in college okay you're some badass
i'm not
okay look callan had his time in in the
barrel but let's can we please shift
over here to brennan just for a second
yeah first of all mr admitted he was
never in any street fights
like you're some badass
these guys are the jock table in high
school but they're adults so it's cringe
right very cringe it's really [ __ ]
cringe so
the walls have been tearing down it's
relation for a while i'm sure callum's
gonna go go back on and pretend like kim
and brendan are best buds
but you're not
because there's there's a what you say
and what's really comes out this is this
is what's coming out
these are two people that it's not like
opie and anthony where they started to
hate each other
they don't think they've ever liked each
other
yeah oh and i started off at you know at
least having two fight together in the
beginning this these two just were
placed together exists this is like if
they placed open anthony together
randomly
when they were both in their 40s yep
exactly they would have hated each other
right off the job
right you're some bad
fighter why are you saying i'm a badass
why are you doing that not being
insulting i'm not being insulting that
is insulting but hold on
you are being insulting oh i get it
royce you're a [ __ ] tough guy yeah i
got it
just like what are you doing i love
white guy who shaves line into his hair
too but something else that needs to be
pointed out white guy who shaves a line
into his hair how old is brent brennan
in his late 30s his 40s what are you
doing man
i just called your balance no no you're
not you're you're being condescending
what you're saying how you're going oh
you grub rich and you haven't thought
don't say that you don't know me why are
you so upset because i have a bad temper
do you see how i'm not upset because i
know it's true exactly because i know
it's true i don't get the phone
you make up a lot of stories i make up a
lot of stories
i make so i'm a liar
yeah
i'm a lie are you [ __ ] me tell me a
story i've made up a real story first of
all be careful now how you speak b
you're telling me you you don't
exaggerate my story i do not lie i i
never lie never lie no i don't lie when
it when it comes to real stories like
saying i'm a black belt saying that i
won the nationals all that are saying i
was a wrestler that's lies have i ever
done that i have character i don't lie
i'm not saying you don't have cure yet
no you are no no if you're saying
somebody's lies then you are inherently
saying they don't have character or a
faulty character at least right
like
you do brendan chop this is what he does
now because we've picked up a lot of
little things in him like he copies the
person he's in the room with
but
it's
there's something childlike about
brendan i've said this before there's
something very childlike about him it's
a childlike brain it's all it's all the
punches of the head
uh in my opinion not a professional
opinion but i think it's all the punches
to the head right
something childlike when you get accused
of lying what's the first thing you as a
kid if you're a kid what's the first
thing you do no you're lying
my teacher was lying i wasn't late my
teacher's a liar everyone's always there
so if somebody else is always a liar
yeah you're never the lot brendan you
were just caught lying you just got
caught lying
i've never said you've never had okay
but you're saying i lied what do you
mean by a lie you you've lied before for
sure give me an example uh late to the
studio all the time missing shows
we're getting a little peek into this
little world boys
late to the studio all the time missing
shows
now we're getting a little this
shouldn't have went out like wouldn't
you just cut that out yeah i would have
cut this well it doesn't matter people
grab because the problem is once you get
gain a reputation of being the show who
deletes stuff and stuff like that
especially when you're big enough like
these guys aren't live are they they
don't live stream
i believe they do no they record and
they premiere i don't think i don't
correct me from wrong can somebody tell
me they're live i'm pretty sure these
guys don't go live live
they they go into that studio and they
film a bunch of these [ __ ] shows and
put them in the cannon and you think so
just put them out yeah
um
again correct me from wrong anybody in
the chat but i'm pretty sure it's
[ __ ] pre-recorded so i'm just saying
and you know not to break the fourth
wall or anything like
if we fought live on the air i would
just be like leave it leave it up
whatever but somebody says this clip is
two years old okay well then they
probably they haven't liked each other
for a while yeah i know what it's the
money it's the same thing [ __ ]
contract they still don't like each
other yeah um
but yeah so it's like if we fought live
i'd be like yeah don't take that down
but if we were pre-recording a show and
we fought i'd probably just be like oh
let's not put that up yeah yeah that
makes sense
yeah no you are not uh i love mack daddy
that's cute royce thought they went live
i'm sorry i don't subscribe to their
channel we don't care nor do i watch it
we get sent stuff of pertinence and we
played it do you think i'm sorry do you
think let's just say for example do you
think when tucker carlson plays a clip
of another news network he's sitting
there watching the entire no we're not
we get said clips
it doesn't change that he called his
co-host a [ __ ] liar it doesn't change
it's irrelevant but you know what wait a
second two years ago bro it's irrelevant
it's not that irrelevant and here's why
it's not that irrelevant because this
bonfire episode was from this year in
may so actually it's not irrelevant
because all that means that it was
backwards that he lied on his show first
or he lied here yeah we're trying to
establish that these two a don't like
each other b both have a history of
lying and see uh you know basically like
i said can't stand each other so
it's almost like if you were on trial
for something
and let's say that like
you know let's say royce is on trial
for uh for financial fraud
and i'm the prosecutor and i dig up the
fact that
two years ago royce was arrested and
convicted of financial fraud you can't
pull this
uh that was two years ago boys we're
trying to establish his character at
this point and establish the themes that
we're trying to push in this case in
this case these two don't like each
other they're both [ __ ] liars and
they're both in this for a paycheck you
show a clip and you go two years ago
this is the screaming 80 show yeah but
that's old though okay but the [ __ ] he
still lied the clip of callan
calling out uh shaab in the beginning
for the pete davidson thing that's also
very recent that's from that's from this
month it's all over last month yeah it's
it's all kind of in the same vein here
comes the real story he's like saying
i'm a black belt saying that i won no no
no no i've never said you've never had
but you're saying i love something else
that brendan does
i don't know if you've noticed this and
this is this is what like people that
think their alphas do
he keeps touching him
like actually making not like point like
he like he touched his knee he touched
his hand kind of like
people do that like in daring you when
they're trying to alfie right like
they're trying to dare you yeah and i
i've had moments in my life where i'm
like if you touch me one more time i'll
have to [ __ ] you up like it's not even
like just stop touching you know i i
don't like being touched anyway i do
have to say this robby don't care on the
chat road uh
this [ __ ] won't even look me in the eye
you'll dna reference
the text that he sent to [ __ ] he
accidentally sent to opie about opie
oh yeah
all right what do you mean by a lie you
you've lied before for sure give me an
example uh late to the studio all the
time missing shows i can keep going on
and i never lied about that because we
all we all love are you sure
well why is it produced guys we all lie
but okay but
you shouldn't right
well they're all la comics something
like guys we were all full of [ __ ] off
yeah percent of the time right
i've never lied about missing shows when
i'm in shows i'm working uh you've been
lazy
what are you doing you're like uh you
you don't make it you've been talking
joking around when i when i go oh
there's a there's a break a main break
what do i do later i've never in my life
in you i've never lived
to you a friend like where i've gone
i've made up a story and then not told
you i was joking around ever ever
what do you talking just keep doing it
dude just do you know me
yeah dude
i i think that when you have a whole
clique that's built on hateable people
they're all gonna start hating each
other i think that that's pretty
standard behavior
right
this is uh somebody else put this
together the chronicles of cte shop have
you seen this
in
a little trolley a little trolley
started all this chaos
um
it's just not
it's kind of tough to decide where to
start however you ever tried throwing a
trolley chin no i don't know what you're
talking about actually
in a trolley
is that what you said
[Music]
conor mcgregor threw a trolley to a bus
window
tell me you know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about
man i is my brain not working right i
don't think i know whatever
it takes actually makes me feel bad for
me i just round out man
are you [ __ ] me i'm not kidding you
didn't see conor mcgregor throw a
trolley through a window i thought
throwing something
i don't know but you solved you're aware
of all this news yeah yeah of course
okay
oh my god wait you're talking about a
dolly a dolly
he meant
he was saying a trolley
he meant
a dolly
and by the way by the way
it's neither
um it was a barricade barricade yeah
it's a metal barricade that you you know
chain a bike to you can also block like
wrestling crowds and people at the msg
that's it was a it was a barricade that
he threw through the [ __ ] i think
this was on below the belt this is one
of his other by the way i that blank
stare
he's done that before too
it's i it's the only time i actually
feel bad for him because there have been
other times people are like oh yeah
you're talking about last wednesday at
the ice house and he'll be like
he just gets like this weird like dear
headlights yeah almost like the slang
and dick thing no but it's almost like
you uh like you completely just
like lost
time for a minute and then you snapped
out of it and you were on stage and
everyone's like
say something royce it's just where
you're like
oh [ __ ] why am i on a stage right now he
has that look i'm like oh god oh god
think of something he just said
something to you and you don't remember
a word he just said
and
what they're saying is so let's say you
like um jerry seinfeld right well who
inspired jerry seinfeld that's gonna
explain all about jay fun seinfeld well
who inspired let's say george carlton if
he's
probably that's it who inspired him
george george
that have not received spring spring
bruce springsteen
he really is punch drunk call him bruce
springster springs ring did he call him
bruce spring spring okay people are
correcting me it was a hand truck it was
a dolly in my bed
fine it was a dolly jesus christ
can you go back a little bit
here i need to hear george carlton again
i need to hear the comedian what they're
saying is so let's say you like um jerry
seinfeld right well who inspired jerry
seinfeld that's going to explain all
about jay seinfeld well who inspired
let's say george carlton if he's
calling let's say who inspired him
george carlin
all right man if you're if you want to
be a comic like there's
there's certain names you should know
right like richard pryor like there's
certain names like richard pryorson
bill hickberg yeah eddie murphree
[Music]
he's so
dude he's he really i don't know what
that last fight did to him
but that man owed some money royce
that last man he fought was him [ __ ]
money
for turning his brain into some sort of
gelatin slash pudding type
uh material
that have not received spring spring
bill crosby somebody wrote me stevens
got me that knockout over dan ho
[Music]
no i said do huh did you yeah or why not
i don't know dan
with fast bender with every i think fast
spreader is is the truth you look at his
background stuff like that and he found
a more legit guy than theorists but
you could what did uh
ethan hawkins have listen i'm a fan of
uh wisca leafy
i can't i'm embarrassed did he call him
wiz khalifi
tell me he doesn't have cte
i think he has cte but here's the other
thing i think i think that he also
and i was guilty of this like when i was
younger when i was much younger but like
when i was in my 20s i just basically
like worked and i went out and partied
and i i just
had an okay life i didn't really do
anything and i didn't really
desire anything and i wasn't really
interested in anything and i didn't
really learn about anything for like a
couple of years of my 20s i was like
whatever dude and like
he's he reminds me of that guy he's got
a nice car and he's always cruising
around l.a and he just [ __ ] chicks and
he just you know what i think he's just
doing is doing his thing at the common
and i don't think he cares and i think
it's cte combined with the fact that he
just has no interests in anything and he
pretends to know everything so he's
constantly being like yeah where's
khalifi bro he's [ __ ] awesome
yeah you know he he's no george carlton
but he he sounds yeah he sounds like
he's mimicking what other people think
is cool like what other people like with
with a comic think of your comic like
you should know carl and you should know
prior you should know blah blah whatever
you know go down the list
he's just
like everything he does that's something
we figured out about him it's he's
he's like when your little brother tries
to copy you
but he doesn't do it just right like
he's trying to copy you to be cool
that's what he is yeah guys i like wiz
khalifi too
that's funny all right yeah that's
that's great
you sound like my dad right there who's
khalifa
well are you sure it's khalifa luckily
yeah yeah
yeah everybody's sure of that even i
know i think you depend well i've heard
both oh really yeah he's wait wait wait
wait
he's
he's heard both
no he hasn't
khalifa you make some nice music
delicious i'd eat that but i don't like
it i don't i don't get done
i don't like rubbery sea urchin [ __ ] the
only thing the only time i've had sea
urchin that i liked was when you put it
with when you mix it with pasta
that's the only time i still don't like
sea urchin
see urchin don't say urgent
ever sea urchin
you are urgent
because i gotta get to the sea urgently
it's huh he's doing good that's a good
joke bro
he's he is
it really is like nice cover-up dude
that's what i mean but it really is like
he's
always panicking and trying to stay
above water verbally
but his brain just can't
no no i see we're talking two different
things because i'm saying right now no
i'd love to get to the sea urgent i feel
like you're covering and then there's
sea urchin oh you were saying i might do
you like i gotta get this urgent yes you
don't like getting into this i like to
be there on my team no i need to take my
time yes okay i thought you were
covering for a second oh no
that makes sense and they they even go
to where henry lee oswald's oh god and
they have to like
they have to cover for each other of
course oh yeah dude now i get it
or he was joking
maybe brandon callum was joking
or being sarcastic
the house was where he stayed henry uh
lee oswald was shot harvey dude don't
you remember henry lee oswald
and it's not even that was harvey's
brother he was like but you even mixed
it up because even if you got it right
it's not harvey lee oswald either it was
lee harvey oswald you dumbass henry he
didn't even
oswald he didn't even at least say lee
henry oswald no it's henry lee
i mean henry lee lucas is the serial
killer but not the same guy you know too
much about serial killers sorry
harvey sorry
it might be ct
fraternity fraternity for uh fraternity
that's why they're supporting umbilical
like trump i mean
so he's reading so you gotta so people
are not watching people not watching
he's reading yeah and he read imbecile
as umbilical he was reading an article
umbilical and and it's
he has to realize right like then he's
not writing this [ __ ] i don't know he
was reading an article okay that means
yeah no no he's reading an article
that's [ __ ] really embarrassing
that's why they like the ufc good god
this guy's so out of touch with reality
yep you're not happy with you i got to
introduce you guys this is tony
hinchcliffe yeah and jeremiah watson
yeah
watkins
even even the guys that
like okay because jeremiah watkins is
i've said before is arguably
one of the funniest guys over there yeah
you said that before he's very much one
of the funniest comedy store uh
performers
and he's gotta really like carry a lot
of water for like tony hinchcliffe and
redband and all these death squad
[ __ ] because he's got a you know
whatever pays dues
um guys like brendan have sort of just
passed over jeremiah like jeremiah
watkins
should be on tour with joe rogan
jeremiah watkins
should be doing
three podcasts you know what i mean like
he's really really funny and he's gotta
come in here and go like uh come in with
tony promote this kill tony [ __ ] i gotta
be nice to this [ __ ] meathead [ __ ]
[ __ ] and on top of that he can't even
get he's at this comedy store every
night the same [ __ ] club royce and he
can't say his name right but you know
what you're right disrespectful you
brought you know you brought something
up that i think really needs to be
talked about there's a lot of people
around brandon shobb that are clearly
using him because he's friends with joe
rogan and it helps boost her shows and
all that stuff
but in reality like
you don't think when these comics are
just hanging out without brenda in there
they're not [ __ ] they have to be
[ __ ] on brendan all like this is a
dude that they probably [ __ ] on all the
time when they're not around him i would
like if this was somebody we knew you
know you would we would just be [ __ ]
on him when he's not around because he's
he's a dumb guy right they can't call
him out publicly because obviously
brennan has the showtime show and he has
a big exposure former ufc fighter so
obviously you know you're you're like oh
this is just gonna help promote my [ __ ]
i get it like and that's a lot of we
talked about carnies earlier
a lot of comics are carnies too a lot of
comics hate each other but they all
pretend to like each other because you
know it's a fraternity man comedians are
like [ __ ] women dude yeah they really
have the same etiquette they have the
same sort of general hey
i loved your set girl i loved it
you know she's [ __ ] rogan right yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] like it's guy comedians
are just as like women it's the same
thing hey too i loved your set dude yeah
man great stuff dude who does tim dillon
think of [ __ ] he is he's going to come
out here and he's going to be like one
of the guys now she thinks he's going to
be just one of us like it's there's so
much self-hatred in the comedy world
it's like literally don't go out even
the ones you like they [ __ ] on each
other they like legit like you'll go to
a diner after a show and you'll all eat
and then one of the guys is like all
right man well anyway good night man i
gotta get back i gotta work in the
morning i'll see you later and then i'll
leave
uh guys i'm just gonna say it man like
he's not that funny he's not that
exactly they wait until they are still
waiting for their over and you're like
god damn man wait for the pull out of
the parking lot
uh let's uh hold on a little bit a
little bit people now the problem is we
get too many clips of him being stupid
being sent my way
by that
blocked hands bro
i'm going i'm going off a little sleep
oh good and a [ __ ] traumatic brain
injury
it's more the traumatic brain injury
than the little sleep right hey man i'm
a little groggy and also mentally
[ __ ]
sorry about that
oh yeah um
sorry my blood sugar's low and i [ __ ]
parts of my brain shut down sorry guys
hey uh i took uh melanin last night
melatonin so i'd go to sleep and uh it
ended up making me sleep really late
today oh also my brain has been turned
into pudding by a far superior fighter
than me fighters fighters fighters by
multiple better fighters
they just you know no matter what no
matter what i did
they just kept punching me in the head
region and then after a while
it got to be unpleasant yeah you know i
mean i legends in the usc like chuck
little
and randy carter
starts naming all these [ __ ] legends
uh titan ortiz uh frank meyer frank
meyer
all these people
admire
frank meyers you never heard him we
broke a bunch of guy's arms i think he'd
frank marry me
moist gracie
take the shoes off the table
two hours of show before this yeah
brendon schaub in his
as producer 25 year old
i can't this guy is just
he's just is he one of the most
cringe people ever no yeah no he is but
like
in any other situation if he wasn't like
buddies with rogan this would be the one
of the biggest locales on the internet
oh yeah no this guy should
he's kind of a low cow but he would be
one of the biggest locals on the
internet if you took away the fact that
rogan and all these guys stand up for
him no if in it there's an alternate
universe right now
where he never became friends with rogan
and he's got a 27 page long kiwi farms
threat yes and people are just going
dude look what brendan sharp did again
they tripped like a [ __ ] look at his
dumb idiot
just be kiwi farms people just go hey
look stupid idiot again can't pronounce
names
[Laughter]
vader versus freaking uh fedor i i
didn't think it would go like that i
thought bador was gonna get an hook
i was kidding about the fighter names by
the way
hey photographers
photographers
yes
why your job is to split why would you
your show time right here's a bunch of
money uh to do a bunch of podcasts and
be one of our professional speakers
you can't you telling me you can't find
any other
former ufc jobber
who doesn't speak
more properly and actually like have a
decent vocabulary and is it a [ __ ] i'm
sure a lot of them are morons but
i've seen a few ufc fighters that know
how to [ __ ] talk you know what i mean
why isn't
cnn no there wasn't cm punk doing a
[ __ ] podcast even he could probably
skate a little bit better than brent
there's plenty of ufc fighters that
could talk and have become actually
decent announcers that's actually true
um
but
look you could be stupid
or you could have cte and still be
successful you can't be both yeah like
muhammad ali was a genius who had cte
right and so he was like
a butterfly stupid even in his old age
he still
could hold it together yeah but he
wasn't a dumb man this guy yeah like he
said he's dumb and he's also you can't
have both like you could be success
honestly this country's awesome right
this country's so cool that you could be
one of the two and still be successful
but he's both
and that and that's what does that's
what puts him over the edge like
everything stacked against him if he
wasn't friends with the rogan community
and all these west coast if rogan wasn't
sticking him in a high chair and going
here's the airplane where would he be
you blockbuster i look forward to seeing
you guys i can't hey my buddy ryan loco
who did uh he's like one of the best
photographers in the world took all my
pictures you want you want to snap some
shots yeah
what's your favorite scorsese film
scrascisi uh
probably mine is bootfellas i like
cassano oh cassano is really good
because cyno is good
dude if you look at over the time of
some great artists like freaking john
lennon or anybody costco
does it physically make you cringe when
he does this costume you know what's
making me cringe even more is watching
chris delia yeah this whole time he's
having none of brendan's job [ __ ] either
chris delia has
absolutely no respect for brendan schaub
in this picture also chris deeley in
this picture looks like nick's stall on
heroin
picasso picasso you wait you don't like
the
they had their [ __ ] man did you see that
evil chinese man ling jingling
and it's over it's over and jingling
puts his
he oh you're right mike now that i've
noticed he's this deer in the headlights
he always seems surprised wait no but
only when people respond to him and
throw him off course yeah be like yeah
last week right like uh i went to the
store i went to the bodega because i was
hungry right oh yeah what'd you get to
eat
and then he just freezes he's always
like um
uh ross campoyo
um
what was i talking about like jesus one
thing throws him completely off track
what is it
jin ling jingling puts his shingle jin
ling hold my
then you're going to have the
lightweight champion and uh khabib go to
welterweight and then you're gonna have
the 145 champ max hollywood paulie mello
my goal
[Music]
i forget but you watch it
[Music]
the rachel divide in this country is
it's been an all-time high imagine
having his brain and trying to use
google
oh right dolezal could you imagine being
like oh what's that girl's name let me
type in rachel dozer into google like
everything he types in would lead him to
nothing everything autocorrects bright
trust no no he's so bad it wouldn't
auto-correct
that's what i'm saying google would just
go there is no rachel does her dude i
don't know what you're talking about
it sounds like a roller rink
what's that roller derby person chinese
mma fighter let me type in one word
jingling
i'm sure that'll lead me to an end
result i'm looking for
different names she changed her name to
like some super does she still want to
be black john elway
by the way rachel divide does sound like
an interracial porn star if we're being
fair
rachel divide sounds like an ecw female
wrestler
yes you're right
oh [ __ ]
owns car dealership won super ball any
beat okay he won super balls okay that's
not anything back to the keto diet so um
i have more knowledge now did you say
taquito diet
city right now so struggle city he is a
15 year old girl washington times i
don't know how reputable they are but
they're pretty reputable they say no
narcotics or alcoholic system when he
died and this one's pretty replica
[Music]
so he copies what brian cowan says and
he calls it reptical they're pretty
reptical they're pretty reptical
reptical news organization when he died
and this one's pretty replica
reptical they're pretty reptical news
organization i would be
[ __ ]
miserable having to do this
yeah
ready for this this is a project had
zero amateur fights
zero not one not 450 like lomachenko not
350 like triple g he's the youngest
champion ever and has zero background
that would be a protege aaron p a
project
go with prodigy product product yeah
so like most of their shows are brian
callan correcting him
is that what it is
you wanna young check versus rose nama
nunes
how do you like that for pronunciation
suck on them you'll see he mispronounced
no i'm sorry i'm sorry he also does
these shows where he rubs his face all
the time it seems like he's just tired
and doesn't want to be there versus rose
how do you like that for pronunciation
he mispronounced
he mispronounced
pronunciations
he's really dumb dude he's a dumb guy